I really feel like this is my Oscar
moment you know what I mean Daniel
day-lewis could suck you how's the
acting
how did she know I was an actor I get
your new Hollywood I'm a traumatic actor
I just moved to town I'm ready to act
yes thank you
oh don't worry this little guy's an
actor oh yeah I'm I'm on season 69 if I
your mother
bad looks good yeah he's yeah he's sober
if I got your back dude we're a duo
who's this sexy actor all right it's not
an actor this is my best friend all
right think actors are stupid
yes what something scary from Gary
Graham ha ha ha ha you're in the game
now yeah my name is Gary I am new to Los
Angeles yeah man totally sub world Rick